[Music]
so I want to talk about performance
prediction and when we do think about
performance prediction in sports we
think about pro athletes elite athletes
and usually these people have a whole
range of electro fancy electronic
devices and medical devices hooked up to
them and and they produce metrics like a
Formula One racecar and all these kinds
of metrics are used to make predictions
for them but how is the world for
amateur athletes so most of us mortals
that just do some running and cycling we
have nowadays affordable watches with
GPS and heartrate at most maybe some
cyclists with that have power meter and
we're limited to that so let's meet
Ellison Bob so Bob is a runner that just
recently started running and exercising
a bit and he's a very busy guy he has
just one hour to 90 minutes a week for
running and it's very soon he will do a
race of 10k and it will be the first
time of his life and he really doesn't
know how to pace himself so he's a bit
uncertain he doesn't want to blow up
halfway in the race and needing to walk
the rest of the distance so he's really
interested in what would be a safe space
for him to reasonably finish his 10k and
at the same time Ellis is very phonetic
running for ten years and in eight weeks
she has a big race and she wants to
break her personal record and then that
is 40 minutes in 10k and that's pretty
tough and now she's doing some very new
fancy training plan and she wants to
know the exact probability of breaking
her personal record in in that race and
she wants to track how the probability
will raise or lower during her training
to see if a training is effective
so traditionally performance prediction
in athletics and endurance athletics was
mostly done by vo2 max measurements so
it's I think even from the 1930s and
exercise physiology they started with
some devices and being able to measure
how much oxygen a person can digest and
consume within a minute and that turned
out to be reasonably correlated with
Leduc performance especially in smart
small distances the problem is that you
need to go to a lab and put on this gas
mask and go to a full AG maximum
exercise test so it's not fun to do as
an athlete so it costs money and time
and is usually not affordable and not
practical for most amateur athletes and
in addition this vo2 max it does
correlate with athletic performance but
especially on a longer distance is
longer than 5k for runners for example
this prediction will become very noisy
so from from scientific literature you
usually see values of r-squared lower
than 0.7 for distances like 5k or 10k so
there's a lot of noise so it's it's it's
not really very usable metric to use for
prediction but somehow it's used
religiously by exercise physiologist and
some products in the market so I once
had a great insight when I follow the
discussion about exercise physiology and
then some people on some subreddit were
discussing who will be the next winner
of the Tour de France and they were
throwing in a lot of arguments about
very detailed metrics of certain
athletes and this guy is this vo2 max
and some power range and curve and and
who will win the Tour de France until
someone broke into the discussion and
simply ask the question hey what was the
reason number of victories for cyclists
a versus cyclist BIA wouldn't that be
the best predictor of who over in
in the next race and basically I'm using
that principle to try to predict
performance for amateur athletes so you
want to predict how someone will perform
at some major event like this marathon
and as such and looking at meters so I'm
looking at not looking at the
performance of these people at the front
row because these are superhuman Bionic
beings but I'm looking at the
performance of the people in the crowd
over there
and since we cannot run a marathon first
to be able to predict how our next
marathon will be tomorrow because we
will be broken already we need to make a
prediction based on training data which
is different there's a totally different
context and totally different
characteristics than the race so the
idea is to look at training data prior
to a race and be able to predict what
the performance will be during a running
race so in a bit more detail this is how
our race data looks like so we have
every row in this table is like an
activity which is a race and the main
characteristic is the average speed and
in the second column so that in this
case it's expressed in meters per second
but it's not too important so at least
we have races they have a timestamp and
they have an average speed now we want
to predict that from training
performance so trainings were training
workouts have a similar granularity as
races there are obviously many more of
them so again there's an average speed
some things like a heart rate but the
thing is with these this data you can
zoom in so this is a different
granularity level this is within one
activity and within every activity you
have second-by-second measurements of
your actual heart rate and the actual
velocity
that the athlete has at that moment and
you see additional columns like if the
heart rate is suspicious so the consumer
devices for training have usually heart
rate measurements but depending on how
it's used and maybe if it is the skin is
a bit dry and for some other reasons
there may be electronic interference the
heart rate may be unreliable so suddenly
sometimes you see very sharp spikes
sometimes you see total flat lines for a
long time and that's an indicator that
the heart rate measurements is not
really reliable or maybe something bad
happened to the person same thing is
there's a column called steady heart
rate is also computed feature so you can
imagine if I'm doing an interval
training and I will suddenly increase my
speed the heart rate is lagging for
those of you that the runners cycle you
will see that phenomenon happened that
if you start sprinting it may take a
minute or two before your heart rate
reached reaches the really high levels
so at that moment when the heart rate is
in flux these are also not really usable
measurements to capture this
relationship between intensity and and
performance so there's an additional
computed feature that says well this
moment the heart rate is relatively
stable so you can visualize that so for
example one activity has this detailed
table and and the part that we just saw
before in this table is this tiny part
of the whole activity so this is an
example of an interval workout so you
can see it takes like 4,000 seconds so
the blue areas are the areas with the
steady heart rate and the red areas are
the areas with the suspicious heart rate
you also see some noise here where the
heart rate monitor seems to be seems to
break down or maybe the athlete is doing
something strange so you need to take
care of all this kind of noise and
basically just use this periods of
steady heart rate
so the next thing that you can do is in
ignoring the time and then creating a
scatter plot for example and comparing
the heart rate at a given moment with a
speed that you had at the same time so
again you see clusters of blue points
these are the points of interest and
they capture the relationship between
the effort that was putting in and the
actual velocity that happens so at this
moment you see a cluster of points for
example when where the heart rate was
slightly above 120 and the speed was at
around 10 10 km/h and these were
probably the interval pieces where the
heart rate got to like 150 and the speed
was slightly above 15 kilometers per
hour so these are indicators of this
person's athletic performance but these
are not necessarily the conditions in
which that person would do a race but at
least we had know something about the
training so the next thing that you can
do is you can try to fit a curve through
these blue points through these points
of steady heart rates and then try to
model with some parameters of that curve
what a relationship is between the
effort and the performance so you can do
this curve fitting because we're
interested in uncertainty you can do
this curve fitting also in a bootstrap
way so you collect data from multiple
activities it takes some sample of
reliable points you fit the curve and
then you resample again then you draw
multiple curves so in this way you can
for example in areas where the data is
sparse so for this person maybe there
was not much data with the heart right
above 150 so you see more uncertainty
about this relationship than for example
at a heart rate of 130
so additional question is what actually
makes for race I talked about races and
you saw this table of activities that
were labeled as race so as it happens
this data that I'm using is coming from
Strava I'm not sure if everyone is
familiar with Strava astrov is like a
social media platform for endurance
athletes and it collects a lot of data
from from many devices and it has an IP
I so users that give consent allow me to
use their data so Strava as a feature
when you upload an activity you can you
can label it as a race or as a workout
or whatever so initially I thought that
would be a nice feature to use to label
my activities as races or not until I
started analyzing the data and creating
some distributions and then some users
obviously we're abusing this labeling to
just use it as their own personal
labeling form with whatever meaning it
had so these bus that's destroyed my
plan to use this feature so I know that
needed to do something else so
eventually I ended up just manually
labeling a few races making a random
forest model simple random forest model
to make predictions and then baked the
worst errors out of the predictions and
labeled them again by hand and in this
way creating some curated data labelled
data set and used it to label all the
remaining activities as either a race or
not race so the results of that is this
distribution of distances so that just
to check that my classifier did some
reasonable job in predicting races you
see a sharp spike at the 5k distance you
see a sharp spike at the 10k distance
the ten miles half marathon and full
marathon and then there's this whole
white space at the rest of this
distribution so what did it would that
mean it goes until 165 kilometers
and actually if he would come really
close this board you see a tiny blue dot
in here and initially I thought that was
an activity that was noise maybe someone
had a bike ride or a car ride
incidentally labeled as a run until I
looked at that race and there actually
happened to be people that run races
over 100 miles so that was a race so
from that process how do I get my
training and test data to fit a model so
over time there are multiple activities
that follow each other so as I explained
before for each activity you can take a
sample of these stable heart rate and
velocity points and combine them and fit
curves so actually we have a fitted
curve model per activity and as they
progress at one moment in time we
encounter a race and at that moment
we'll look back at the previous activity
and we have this function this curve fit
and we can sample from this uncertain
distribution some some points at
different intensity levels so for each
athlete you desert you determine based
on their maximum heart rate three so
high medium and low intensity heart rate
of exercise and you sample some
performance some some velocity from
these points so for every training
workout you actually have a vector of
three elements which has the performance
at low medium and high intensity and you
can compare that with the average speed
that you saw during the race so that
gives us an x and a y that we can use as
training data so as an illustration
making disjoin
and so this gives a visualized
visualization of the distribution of
these training data compared to the race
data so at the column level you see at
the left column these are all the this
is all the training data with a low
intensity medium intensity and a high
intensity and on a row level you see the
distances so the top one is a very short
trek distance races like 800 meters
these are 5k races 10k races half
marathon and full marathon and already
you can see that depending on the
distance of the race and the intensity
during training you can see that some
combinations have naturally a better
correlation than others so for example
for a full marathon you see that this
high intensity performance is not really
does not correlate very well compared to
the low and medium intensity and
similarly for the for the trek level
activities you see that low intensity
performance during training does not
really predict well what the race will
be so this already suggests that just
fitting a single model on this entire
piece of data will not give an optimal
result no not entirely so the density
plots that you see are relative
so that enters the the usage of
probabilistic models because also
initially our personas were interested
in probabilities and bandwidth of
reasonable performance so this is a
natural way to to model this so I'll
shortly explain how probabilistic model
works for people that don't know so a
probabilistic model first of all it
needs to be defined by the data
scientist it's not that you can just say
I have a random forest model and these
are my parameters and go fit I need to
create the structure of this model so I
need to say that I need to specify the
deterministic function that determines
my y hat so in this case I use a very
simple model that actually just said
takes the weighted average of these
three performances at the different
intensity and this model should learn
the weights of this weighted average and
the probabilistic model so this you see
this medium low and high English words
coefficients of my weighted average
model are being generated by priors
so probabilistic model works by so my
function is for example mu equals and
intercept alpha and below times my
observed low intensity training and this
beam medium coefficient times my medium
training coefficient etc and these
values for these coefficients are
randomly generated in one step by these
priors and the dice maybe for the water
really networks that the dice suggest
that this coming from a uniform
distribution but you can specify what
kind of distributions you want to sample
from so in my case I choose exponential
distributions because I want them to be
either zero or something meaningful but
not something
very small so in one round you make a
sample from these priors and you plug in
your X in this function and this is
combined by the sampled coefficients
also for the for the intercept and it
leads to a value of y and for my whole
data set you will get multiple Y's so
eventually you will have a distribution
coming out of that of your Y's and you
can compare the distribution with the
observed Y's which is the race actual
race distances so depending on how much
these two distributions correspond or
not there will be a likelihood and based
on that you either select or reject the
sample that you chose for your
parameters a repeat this process on and
on like if you want to have 1,000
samples for 10,000 samples you repeat
this process 10,000 times there are
different kinds of samplers that that
determine how exactly at each round new
samples are chosen because they may
depend on the previous round so the end
result of a probabilistic model is not
like a random force you will have a
fitted model with a few parameters that
are set to specific values but you will
simply have a large distribution of
model parameters so actually a fitted
probabilistic model is nothing else than
a big numpy array which is as dimensions
the number of parameters in my model
times the number of samples that I chose
that's that's the fitted model that you
have so finally this is an example of
what we call a pooled model so
regardless of the distance of the race
and regardless of the user I pick the
whole population from the sample that I
have and I fit my coefficients for this
whole population
so I used by mc3 so last year I learned
a bit about how to use our MC 3 I was
before that usually mainly using just
scikit-learn or other machine learning
algorithms but never played with
probabilistic modeling so what is fine c
3 it offers actually it's just a bunch
of samplers so every sampler is is a way
is a strategy and algorithm that chooses
like a sample from these priors based on
some some algorithm and and basically
that's it that is prime C 3 so prime C 3
offers a domain-specific language in
Python in which you can specify your
model you can specify what kind of
sampler you will use and you can just
press the what they call the magic and
ferrous button and it will produce
samples for you and besides that it just
offers a few summaries and utility
functions to to diagnose the sampling
process so here's an example of
specifying that that pooled model that
you just saw and by mc3 so the top
couple of lines are just a specification
of my priors so i say i have an
exponential distribution for this low
medium and high intensity here i specify
the the function that the determines mu
so so my y hat and this is the
likelihood and here i plug in do you
observed y values and then it's it's
just a matter of calling sample on this
model object and by mc3 will do the
sampling magic for me and produce a big
number array with the sampled values of
my model parameters so for this pool
model as an example it's what we call
the posterior predictive so we created
the sample of
model coefficients and then we predict
our own training data with these model
coefficients we get a distribution of
predicted Y's predicted race speeds so
the orange line is what was actually
observed and the blue line is the
distribution that was generated from
this sample so you see that this is
already quite a reasonable model so the
nice thing is you can also plug in new
data and make a single prediction so for
example I picked two of my recent races
that I run
so one 10k one half marathon and made
this model make a prediction for me
based on my training data so you see
here the distribution of expected speeds
during the races and and the vertical
lines are the actual realized speeds
that I got during the races so you see
that it's already in my case at least
it's doing a reasonably good prediction
but the nice thing is that it's also it
doesn't do a point prediction it gives
me an uncertainty range and and also
allows me to move to make this problem
accept probability so if I would have
asked the model now what is my
probability of doing this 10k faster
than 17 kilometers an hour it would
simply mean the the surface below this
plot on the right and that can be easily
computed from the sample it's already
this achieves the goal of our personas
so you can also use UNPO improve models
so instead of looking at the whole
population you can make these
coefficients doing a group by so I
created bins for every type of distance
and then you can learn a separate model
actually per type of distance so
actually this is like a group by dot fit
I wants particularly nice property of
probabilistic models is that you can
create a hierarchy in your model so the
previous example I showed of the pool
model that there was a likelihood and
there was a level of the priors and
these projects were hard-coded but now
you can also create a new level of hyper
priors that actually determine what what
the individual priors will be so you
also now see a number of 12 here because
in my model I make a distinction by
distance so there are 12 different
distances there are the these typical
arrays distance but also the the spaces
in between so that means we now have 12
times four parameters in our model and
this model automatically does the
grouping by but compared to the unpooled
model where a model is trained on every
subgroup in isolation now because of
these hyper priors this hyper priors
will learn what the population mean will
be for this subgroup and then level out
the coefficients of every group that it
will train so that means if you have
very small groups that deviate from the
population mean this will be dampened
that's what what you call shrinkage in a
Bayesian modeling so you see here's an
example in the in the unpooled model
where every model was just trained in
isolation of area for every subgroup you
see that the coefficient for for example
medium intensity training for ultra long
races got a value of 0.26 it's just a
value of the coefficient well in a mean
in the population mean for the pooled
model it only had a value of point zero
seven and there are not many people that
do this ultra marathon kind of runs so
it may be that this is some kind of
overfitting on this very small subsample
so that's what you see in a partially
pooled model with is these meta priors
that this value for this coefficient
coefficient is very much smaller than
and in the unpooled model so it moves
towards the population mean so you can
do even more crazy things so I the the
first kind of pooling that on pooling
that I introduced was based on distance
but you can also do it in a user level
so if in my case there were this
training set represented 230 users I can
create an unproved model with 230 users
as the category that is grouped by and
also the twelve distances so this will
be more than 10000 parameters in this
model for only 1,600 observations so of
course that that's a recipe for
overfitting that's what you see here so
this is an overview of separate
combinations of pooled unpooled partial
pools etc and I compared the training
and test error especially what you see
here is that in the for this unpooled
model with both distance and user used
as categories so the train error was
really good it dropped significantly but
then the test error was out of
proportion so that that's a clearly a
case of overfitting well you see even
with this granularity of the model if
you use this partial pooling mechanism
the overfitting is really reduced so in
this case this is still a model with
more than 10000 parameters on 1,600
observations and the amount of all
fitting is quite limited so this model
can be useful even
so some of the learnings for me it's
really useful to have in depending on
the business case distribution of model
parameters instead of a single metric so
you can compute this uncertainty
intervals and also to your end users you
can you can choose to present some some
reason some way of uncertainty and for
this type of model prediction the
hierarchical models with this partial
pooling seems really promising because
maybe at my first experiments going on a
user level may be too detailed and
introduced too much overfitting but
maybe I can find out some characteristic
of user groups for example the amount of
time they train or their ambitions or
whatever that may be slightly less
granular and less prone to overfitting
and which may improve the performance of
the model even more and again not
something I worked on yet but given a
discussion that we had yesterday also
about the empathy and knowing our users
so if we go back to Bob and Alice for
example both of them may be impacted
differently by model error for example
Bob wants to have a safe speed so if the
model is too optimistic about Bob speed
Bob will may starts too fast honest NK
and will drop dead some summer halfway
while Ellis which wants to know this
probability before and if the model
would be too negative Ellis will not see
any improvement and maybe become
stressed because of it and will try to
push harder and maybe get injured so
depending on the user you ma you want to
handle this model error in a different
way
so let's conclude by some result of a
very very long
sarcastic process are there any
questions
[Applause]